that's all my head I got it I just gotta
put pen to paper we got this we can
really win this game
anxious baby
[Music]
[Applause]
whatever I thank you this was the last
Monday morning in her life
[Applause]
just like the Sun that night who knew
has to work a lot which is what I would
say when it falls into work that's in
between what vaynermedia does or another
digital agency does and what a Boston
Consulting the thing does around
transformational digital right so
Internet of Things you know you know
top-level domain you know new emerging
things or even like hard core you know
what's our Facebook's video strategy to
replace the television commercials and
making a Facebook environment you know
things like that a lot of heavier
thinking
Oh
[Music]
wasn't always wrong you and some
my friend
[Music]
I appreciate
[Music]
is love
you know I'll be okay with that
um you know first year you help me kick
off a DJ project second year you help me
again
pick off piece a week yep and I learned
a lot both times and natural progression
is to go one a month but you go as deep
dude you can go for the piece and what I
want to do is collaborate every single
month with a different person I want to
sit down and say okay so kick it off
with you right and say it's going to be
the Vaynerchuk Beach I want to sit down
to a 20 30 minute talk to you or what
some people have more time than me or
sit down with for 2-3 hours
absolutely or 2.2 days obviously someone
like you I've been two days totally
totally distracted video and then reduce
that message good but I found is
powerful about the [ __ ] I do is I can
reduce a story like into a place where
story tell written right the way I'm a
storyteller my way you are in your way
dude every [ __ ]
I love you man good luck to you you got
to be well there's all that you're on
going on
104 stun hey how are you I'm really well
how are you I'm freaked out that's a
good strategy we don't want it we don't
want to spend our entire 60-second Club
on the free cap no no not at all
very cool so so what do you want to do
in our time here I actually wanted to
know I know that in a couple of your
snaps you said you know you have a
family and I know you don't show like
your kids on snap and stuff like that
but I'm just curious on how how you
balance it all I kind of do a couple
different things and never you know it
for a while there I kind of felt like I
had everything at least you know up in
the air and then it kind of all came
down and now just trying to get
everything spinning again I just feel
like I'm doing good
that I'm failing in another and I just
want to know how you balance it all I
think I balance it all by not judging
myself too harshly I think that's really
where it starts and stops I think way
too many people have lost the work-life
balance before it even started because
they're going to be critical on
themselves regardless of it right it's
so hard to balance and so for me I just
know I'm doing the best that I can and
if I'm doing the best that I can that in
itself has put me in a position to
succeed and some days that means that I
have to choose my family time at a
Friday night or a Sunday morning
an executive ran into me on Saturday and
asked me to meet for coffee and wanted
to jam and I just couldn't you know I
couldn't cuz of the family time right
and so that's the family being chosen
other times I'm you know flying and
speaking somewhere or meeting having a
big meeting and I'm missing you know
some sort of like school function that I
don't want to miss and that's the other
way and the truth is I just don't beat
myself up all of us are trying the best
we can and so as long as it you know
nothing is glaring and to me glaring is
the following my kids have become
completely horrible people that have
major problems in society and or I go
directly out of business and my
businesses as long as neither one of
those are happening I think it's going
to be okay and so I think it's how you
judge how you're balancing way more than
the reality of it and recognizing that
you have a different point of view on it
then you're a partner then the kids then
your business associates and I think you
need to care about your point of view on
it first and foremost while being
empathetic to everybody else's points of
view awesome that's a really good answer
I know that yeah it's hard to try and
not judge what what you're doing and
stuff like that that's the game right
like that's like like everybody could be
failing at work-life balance if they've
decided they're failing at work like
balance so as long as you know you're
not as long as your spouse or your
partner isn't saying I want to break up
or get a divorce and as long as your
kids
are like eating pine tar and as long as
you're you know banks aren't coming to
foreclose your business you're gonna be
okay you know and I think people are
freaking out like that means see my dad
until I was 15 and I love him and we
have the best relationship like there
are people who've had their fathers walk
out on her family and they didn't seem
for 15 years and now they have great
relationships because they've reconciled
like people are way too judgmental and
overanalyzing work-life balance in
today's modern PR society and so if you
feel good about it then you'll win and I
think not judging yourself too harshly
because it is hard to balance everything
because that's life and I'm just I just
I don't aim for perfect I'm not
interested in perfect it's not real
perfect is fake and so I just live thank
you you're welcome
it feels better right like it's like it
feels better to like look at it that way
yes I said it's hard and I said what's a
little guy you know little kids and
stuff you know it's like mommy's not
here daddy's not here and that's kind of
all they see um you know as much as
they're involved it's just kind of hard
some days and they're tougher than you
think
how old are they three and eight three
and eight tell me anything you remember
of being three go much interesting being
in hospital right and and you know what
when you really like like as long as
your counterbalancing it with love and
you know one of the biggest things I you
know all these parents judging people
meanwhile they're around because they
work 9:00 to 5:00 but if they're not
deploying love and are in it from 5:00
to 9:00 every night and on the weekend
what are they really accomplishing just
cuz you're there doesn't mean you're
there right does it do when you do have
your family like you said when you have
your family time you just kind of say
that's family time and that's kind of
not yeah that might be different times
but yes and and sometimes it you know
most the time it works out but sometimes
it does it right like sometimes I can
get distracted and I'm just not willing
to beat myself up if I decided to go
down a rabbit hole for an hour on a
Sunday when I should have been all in on
the family that's just gonna happen like
I just this is about not beating
yourself up and knowing where your
intent and your efforts are and also
knowing life's a long game
so in two three years when I'm
taking my kids on business trips and
traveling with them and showing them the
world like that's where the benefits
have come from some of the sacrifices I
don't know I think everybody you know if
they have the option of what would you
rather have had your parents around
every minute from one to five but not be
able to do all these amazing experiences
with them from 11 to 18 versus the
alternative I just have a funny feeling
all of us who raise our hand and saying
I'll take that 11 to 18 [ __ ] and I plan
on dominating that and some of the
sacrifices I have to create between one
to eight is something I'm willing to do
and that's my strategy and I don't give
a [ __ ] if some parenting blogger says
that I'm not spending enough time with
them [ __ ] you but yeah let me come in
your Emmy plus let me come and judge you
from afar you know what I mean yeah so
yeah there's too many people out there
doing that I love your attitude and I
love your message and that you know I've
started following you a couple months
ago and I just I look I wait for your
content every day I really like it in
fact there's some days that I'm like I
know that sometimes it's you know
someone's like I don't have time or this
and that you're like I'm gonna go out at
their social media and I'm like maybe my
social media tell me that I'm doing at
this point but I really appreciate you
taking the time effect I was running
from my daughter's dance lesson with her
yesterday as I'm commenting on your post
and hashtagging and I got home and my
family was I was like I get to talk to
Gary Vee and my husband's like um I
don't know what that means he's like
that
what's that listen honestly and thank
you right now I'm feeling really good in
my stomach because I knew I wanted to do
this 60s I want you know I figured out
my health by tricking myself into a
system where I was accountable to
somebody else I knew that I wanted to do
something more for my community even
though that I feel like I'm at the top
of the game I wanted to be better than
my best self and I needed to trick
myself into a game that made me bring
more and at this moment right now I'm
super happy I've never been happier
about this 60s you know the 60-second
Club is fun because it's fun to see how
many comments and you get in this
crazy and that's all fun but this chat
made it better well thank you very much
I appreciate you taking time take care
bye bye bye that was fun 60 second club
gotta trick yourself you just need to be
smart about them we're going heavy up
front on that I'm not sure that's right
thought I my father is that we need to
position how we're different than holy
companies so much a workflow perspective
but say that we're still in call
ourselves matrices that's what we are
and we are I do too I just wonder if
it's something I talk over to and we
just show that we're the best modern day
digital agency in the world you know I'm
just debating that and I and I actually
think that sells better but but I'm
still consuming this keep going right so
I'm just wondering if that's even
something we want us like how do we even
sell that without me is something worth
debating yeah okay I don't think it's a
hard story to tell
yeah I guess yeah I guess I guess okay
let's keep going like cool so then we go
into determining what a full-stack
agency is so it's consumer attention
Mary's like the fact that we've
constantly changed we're not married to
any specific channels so this is where
we feel like we need to kind of like
stab dump and backup the fact that we
say what we won't would say recent
recent statistics in fact so consumer
attention is fragmented cause channels
have some facts here to back that up
okay with new channels arriving ever
faster is where we show like adoption
those channels is happening at scale so
quickly alone yeah it's gonna end up
being it's no worries thank you so much
good weeks week for yourself yeah it's a
lot less to this I think the place where
we will get even more reaction is if
this said it's time to stop making
commercials and deploying and deploying
digital 1.0 behavior like like where I
get a lot of traction is I'm not even
going to bother you about commercials
let's talk about the fact that
everything you're doing is banner and
search and you're not even adapting to
the loke the modern web it's time to
stop making TV commercials and deploying
a 1999 through 2010 digital behavior
that will work and obviously we tweak
that a little bit but that's the energy
it will work and and and we're not we're
getting rid of in 1999 to 2010 correct
this slide says it's time to stop making
TV commercials right yeah I think you
start deploying I think it's it would be
like work we're getting discarding I
think we've you are it got it yeah okay
yeah I'm just looking at the case
studies one thing that I want to talk
about is uh is um I don't like this
slide so much I don't think it's a big
enough disparity I don't like it at all
I'm just talking about the honey apart
one thing we don't talk about is how we
think about images
on Facebook an Instagram as print and
billboards versus banners at print
billboards and banners like the modern
way of doing it it's another way to do
more of that work that I believe in and
some just something that doesn't come
across here shows our other capabilities
besides video so just something to think
about I also like some of the Vayner
smart work oh it's right here got it
good okay
place to spend your money those are two
things that stand out that and probably
our favorite videos don't we have some
other CPG videos that we can feel good
about in some way yes I was showing I
see see I really like Swedish fish and
another video that I another slide that
I think would work we have made the
modern TV commercial aka Facebook videos
for all of these brands and then have
little screenshots of mountain dew and
and the logo mound ooh and a screenshot
from the video just an overwhelming
showing we're doing this a lot like
anybody we've made a facebook video for
I think we should show in the same way
that we used to use logos and see for
our clients you see where I'm going that
will really be well at home yeah I'm
also rising we don't have any chase work
in here which is right and we have great
videos for chase like all of it like
let's get every video every single logo
that we've done a facebook video for I
want and if it takes two slides because
we show 18 screen shots and 18 logos and
next one is 18 and 18 Mazel Tov I want
to understand everybody's doing it and
were the kings of it that those facebook
video drive home and then a much deeper
phone to our media capabilities and and
that's that
great okay okay
show me the next version when you get a
chance to cool all right we can make
these pretty quickly too which is good
yeah okay thanks guys
Thanks why do pudy pie closed down as
YouTube it's gonna happen we're gonna
win this is gonna happen it's gonna work
unlike the old days of 20k when was all
creative it was all organic five
thousand and adds a month I know what to
do with on Facebook I know what to do
with influencers we've got all these
accounts of [ __ ] god this is real
like I'm not [ __ ] gaining 10,000
[ __ ] followers on Instagram a day we
hear a lot over a lot of people it's not
cheap to read me it's no I know
but I think I think the the team that we
have could run for for that price of
like 15 to 20 K like I think we can run
for you're also pretty more way more a
local papers local bloggers and closures
like it's just it's all my head I got it
I'm just gonna put pen to paper we got
this we can really win this game you got
me good I'm done there's a tough day a
lot of [ __ ] going on
[Music]
you
[Music]